and the wind is not a factor
now but
it will be later today and off and on
again all week long beautiful view from
the strat looking up to the north at the
city hall
the plaza hotel and of course the circa
not bouncing around a whole lot the
official temperature 63 out at reed
international but we're dipping into the
50s for aliente also down south at
mountains edge you got the low 60s for
the lakes and for summerlin 64 along the
strip of course cooler up at kyle canyon
62 for you guys around the air force
base but man you get outside of nevada
and beyond ely you're below the freezing
mark good morning to cedar city you're
right at 32
for tonopah you're close to the freezing
mark death valley the hot spot as you
might expect at 76 reno down to the low
40s again the wind will be picking up
throughout the day today as an area of
low pressure comes onshore in the
pacific northwest we'll show that to you
in a second we're going for a high of 89
today which would put us a few degrees
above normal we were in the mid 80s
yesterday our current temperature the
low so far
no threat to the record how about 107 on
this day back in 1947.
so more wind is on the way and then once
this low pressure system comes onshore
the wind direction will shift and we'll
have northerly winds tomorrow with
cooler temperatures but here we go with
some rain and snow in the pacific
northwest
now to your family and friends some very
strong storms through south central
nebraska and even some rain around
wichita wanted to show you this
incredible storm chaser video from
outside of wichita this is from reed
timmer who is also a storm chaser look
at that that is in andover kansas which
is a suburb of wichita but man that is
some classic tornadic storm activity
with the debris field being pulled right
up into that funnel cloud all the way up
into maybe 10 or 15 000 feet in altitude
while there's obviously tons of damage
no fatalities reported so that is the
good news there let's get back to the
computer now get your eight day forecast
going from 89 today the winds upwards of
40 miles an hour north winds to 25 drop
the temperature to the low 80s but then
the roller coaster goes right back up in
fact we are going to see the warmest
temperatures of the year so far later
this week some neighborhoods will be
knocking on the door of triple digits
officially we think it will be in the
mid 90s next round of wind drops to
temperatures from 90 saturday down to
the low 80s on sunday